s'évader de la réalité du quotidien
entouré par des oeuvres inspirante et
des idées nouvelles
c'est le pari d'oasis immersion et de
l'exposition inspiration présenté au
palais des congrès
[Musique]
couleurs sons lumières les visiteurs
déambuleront dans des galeries merci le
totalisant plus de 2000 mètres carrés
on aborde l'inspiration sous l'angle des
bouleversements qu'on a vécu en 2020
qu'est ce qu'on en retient quels aspects
positifs et l'aspect d'espoir on en
retient
qu'il s'agisse du voyage spatial de
david saint jacques du travail de
création d'alexandra stréliski ou de la
réflexion du réalisateur et youtube a
émis le roi sur la dernière année
oasis immersion souhaite donner de
l'espoir énergisé et faire méditer les
visiteurs le but du projet c'est de
faire rayonner la culture québécoise le
talent québécois mais c'était aussi de
partager un espace multimédia muséale de
type schiergen en attendant de pouvoir
accueillir les spectateurs dansaient
salle oasis immersion sera offert dans
un premier temps à la clientèle
d'affaires que ce soit l'atelier des
linières à paris le mori dj talent de
tokyo où harry affiche tina las vegas la
tendance est au parcours immersif et
celle approche retenue par le palais des
congrès pour plaire à sa clientèle
internationale mais aussi pour permettre
aux québécois de s'approprier ce lieu
emblématique de montréal on a décidé de
le faire pour justement innover sortir
un peu de des centres de congrès
traditionnelle en offrant une fille
mercy vous avec des émotions on peut
créer des émotions ici au palais passé
c'est quand même rare avant on avait
seulement des gens de l'international
principalement qui venait on attire les
gens locaux
on veut vraiment que les gens ressortir
ressources et inspiré puis qu'ils
repartent avec des beaux souvenirs en
tête puis qui reconnaissent montréal
à travers ce qu'ils ont vu oasis
immersion c'est une expérience hors du
temps apaisante qui lui permet de
voyager dans l'imaginaire grâce à
l'ingéniosité des artisans d'ici
à découvrir au palais des congrès en
2021 ici n'est bien alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal
[Musique]